la bandera ucraniana volvió a
ondearnición un símbolo de la
contraofensiva de kiev en el noreste y
cium en la región de harkif es una
localidad estratégica situada dentro del
territorio recuperado por el ejército
ucraniano tras meses bajo control ruso
nuestra ciudad está hablando francamente
a las puertas del bombazo la región de
doníes empieza a 50 kilómetros de aquí
lo que es el principal objetivo de Putin
estábamos casi que resignados a que las
tropas rusas nunca se fueran
tanques marcados con la z abandonados
tras La retirada el pasado fin de semana
de miles de tropas rusas La mayor
derrota de Moscú desde el mes de abril
cuando los Soldados del kremlins se
marcharon de los alrededores de kiev
la vista es muy impactante pero no es
impresionante para mí porque comenzamos
a ver las mismas imágenes de hucha de
los primeros territorios desocupados
Entonces es lo mismo edificios de
aquellos personas asesinadas
Rusia todavía domina una quinta parte
del territorio ucraniano
Moscú asegura que La retirada de la
región de harkif responde a una
estrategia de repliegue en el don vass
Mientras tanto en las zonas liberadas
por kiev hay quien recupera cierta
alegría
te he estado Esperando te he estado
esperando sabía que volverías estoy muy
feliz llegué casi a perder la esperanza
Pero al final ha vuelto a florecer mamá
sabía que regresaría por ti
insistió en que Ucrania ganará esta
guerra un deseo compartido por la Unión
Europea que según la presidenta de la
comisión Úrsula vonderleyen permanecerá
del lado de kiev a pesar de la
represalias energéticas del kremlin